I'm so honored to say that Camden
and Colton are joining us right now.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
Hi, guys.
Hey, it's a pleasure to meet you.
Thank you.
Camden, it's such an honor to meet you.
I love your story.
What was it, Camden, that...
Was there sort of the aha moment?
Was there an origin story or a spark to the flame?
What was it that got you started?
Yeah, so at the height of the pandemic,
me and my brother were sitting and watching TV
and there was all these news reports that were popping up.
And it was anxiety-provoking, seeing these families.
Me and my brother were really compelled to help
and make a difference.
And our families, or our family always instilled in us
to help other people and put people before you put yourself.
And it was at that moment that we knew kind of
that we needed to do something.
So Colton, what do you do in that moment?
You look to each other, you feel that feeling, then what?
Well, I think our first step
was just talking to our parents
because, I don't know, they have great influence on us.
And yeah, I don't know, that was just our first step,
talking to our parents
and just talking about how to get the word out there
and how to get people to help us, too.
Oh, I think your parents must have been so proud
of you in that moment.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
I mean, I have two daughters
and anytime they come to me on their own
wanting to do something of service, or for someone else,
or a thought that's beyond themselves,
I am just so relieved and excited.
And I'm amazed that your parents were able to leap
into action the way they did.
Explain what Beyond the Crisis means.
So Beyond the Crisis really has to do
with kind of going beyond the crisis.
Because we all know about the current pandemic
and what that caused for a lot of people
and how that was such a huge issue.
But food insecurity is an everyday problem.
It's an ongoing problem.
And we really wanted to address that
on top of kind of the exacerbated effects caused
by the pandemic.
So it was really that that kind of pushed us
to get started, get working.
I mean, you guys are so amazing.
Really, every word you're saying, I'm just hanging on it.
(audience applauds)
And you have helped over 1,000 families,
1,000.
Yes.
I mean, that is just an incredible feat.
And some have actually called you personally
to say thank you.
Did that happen?
Yeah. Yeah.
So actually, there was a lady that showed up in our driveway
and she had an apple tree,
and she reached out to us via email.
And she even was so kind of compelled
and inspired by our story that she showed up
on our doorstep with all of these apples.
And it was just a really heartwarming moment
for my brother and I.
(audience applauds)
Oh, what a poetic way to know you're on the right path.
Your life could have looked so different,
but this is your story now
because of the steps you've taken.
And we're so amazed by what you're doing.
And then our friends at Lundberg Family Farms
are donating $10,000-
Oh, my God.
(audience cheers)
Whoa.
Worth of nonperishable
rice and snack items.
(audience applauds)
Wow.
And they just wanna help
foster your pantry.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Me and my brother appreciate it.
I mean, this is how you're inspiring people,
let alone companies, who are watching you, going,
we wanna be a part of that.
It's so beautiful what you are compelling everybody to do.
And we wanna make sure that you go to our website
at thedrewbarrymoreshow.com
because maybe you have something
that you wanna contribute to Camden and Colton.
I know I certainly do.
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
May I ask, as a last question...
I always like to learn from people
who are about action and not just words.
May I ask a piece of advice, Camden?
Yes.
On how I can better serve my community?
I actually have an answer, all right.
Great.
I was gonna say that I'm 13 and my brother is 18.
So I think it's kinda inspiring that you can be any age
and you don't have to have, you have to be...
Oh, I don't know. (laughs)
You don't have to be 40 and 50 to make a difference.
(audience laughs)
We really
wanted to instill-
Messed that up.
In other teenagers that just by taking a few steps
and moving forward that you can make a huge difference.
And that's why I'm here today.
(audience applauds)
(Colton laughs)
And Colton,
the name you give to a 13-year-old human
is one of the most beautiful I've ever seen.
So truly, thank you for being you.
And your age is just even more amazing because you're right.
It is an ageless thing to take care of others.
You could be older or younger and anything in between.
And I think that's a very valuable lesson.
And we want takeaways in this world.
We wanna be inspired and then know how we can do it.
So your advice is, at any age, you can do this.
Thank you.
That's perfect.
(audience cheers)
Perfect, perfect, perfect.
Camden and Colton, thank you so much.
And thank you to our friends at Lundberg Farms. Thank you.
It means so much to our show that you would help us do this.
(upbeat pop music)